Gus March
Phillips I have a mission I want you to
lead thank you Sergeant what's the plan
to neutralize the German UB boats in the
North
Atlantic we're losing the
war Hitler is not playing by the rules
so neither are
we we both know that time not very
popular with the administration the
reason they find you unattractive is the
very reason I find you a
attractive if I'm to do this I'll need
my own
team you won't like them go they're
all bad they'll need to
[Applause]
be this is an unsanctioned unauthorized
mission
[Music]
if we fail England will be condemned to
a lifetime under the German boot The
[Music]
Bu and so I said that is not a dog that
is my
wife it's very
good
[Music]
one
you and your operation are
Reckless this Mission
now hello can't hear you please
do
[Music]
off